recording hi guys I'm here with Mary
Hart okay why don't they get in mametown
oh yeah okay bilingual that's not like I
I went on Twitter and I asked you guys
for your questions that you wanted
answered and so we're gonna answer some
really hard eating questions right now
first question what's happening oh wait
I don't we're in a hotel because we are
doing a panel tomorrow because we're
both professional and ISL trust us to
talk about things you guys do it is how
do you recover from an embarrassing fart
oh one I look to see if there is a dog
within like five feet of me cuz you can
very easily blame a fart and a dog they
can't speak English or your native
language like yeah just two guys they
don't speak [ __ ] Hawaiian why like
there's like what is what is Aloha then
what do you call that
okay like a buffer well the first thing
I would say is that embarrassing fart is
an oxymoron I think you should own it
own it own it but I will say that
yesterday I was in Michaels craft supply
store I was going there to get some
googly eyes for a video that you'll see
later I was walking about like the like
the jewelry be dial and there was an
older man in front of me and he stopped
and I'm not kidding I was a foot behind
him and he went
looks like you go for it bro I was
either gonna throw up or just like just
moved aside and I moved to the side he
owned it so hard that I was like come on
with you wait am i Cal ders how did he
just kept going he's man he didn't even
acknowledge it he like reaches arm out
to get some like I don't know pincher on
koozie kit and just ripped ass I was
texting people don't you don't even know
what just went down in Michaels I might
I may or may not keep this story and but
that's like one of my favorite stories
of Mary is that she slept over on my
count
and then I race is held at this time had
like like walls around remember like it
wasn't full walls like yeah ceiling was
open you can huge Lina happens in every
room
maimry slipped over she's live on the
couch and I woke up and she was like she
could hear that lesson it was like what
I didn't hearing she's like I farted so
loud in my sleep I woke myself up and
then just started laughing hysterically
I realized where I was I wanted just
done thank you for this picture imagine
you're like just sleeping that's almost
couch and all the sudden you do this
ready
and then here's like waiting for someone
else to notice what's the weirdest thing
you've ever put in your mouth
listen I don't put things in my mouth
unless I'm gonna suck it or eat it so
next question
so I guess why I'd love it or list it
I'm gonna list it you guys ah I always
want them to love it I don't want them
to list it
[ __ ] tweet and that's my favorite I
had a hard week what does your hair
mm-hmm
what does your hair smell like oh well
here's my hair smells like H&M because I
was trying one of those doughnut things
it just looks like a little sponge
yes mouth a circular sponge yeah so I
tried cuz I like no hair and I want a
top line so I did it around it so then I
think I just kind of smell like an aged
new it smells great well thanks what's
your hair smell like I don't know gross
me regret sick smells like it smells a
salad like a non memorable like you're
not gonna smell this hair and be like
that smells specific you're not going to
call that hair the next day no my last
one explain the internet in one word
by oh I don't know
II